AMAZON BOOK FAIR
( APPLAUSE )
AMAZON HAS OVER 12 MILLION
BOOKS.
SO, YOU KNOW, THEY CAN'T ALL BE
DOSTOEVSKY OR "HARRY POTTER."
I'M GOING TO SHOW THE COVER OF
LESSER KNOWN WORKS WE FOUND ON
AMAZON AND I WANT YOU TO TELL ME
THE NAME OF A CHAPTER YOU THINK
SHOULD BE IN IT.
FIRST ONE: CRAFTING WITH CAT
HAIR.
NICK.
>> CHAPTER 10-- TROUBLESHOOTING.
SO YOU KILLED YOUR CAT.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WAS GOING TO
SAY.
>> POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
THIS IS GOOD.
HOW TO DATE A WHITE WOMAN, A
PRACTICAL GUIDE FOR ASIAN MEN.
NICK THUNE, WHAT'S A CHAPTER IN
THIS BOOK.
>> CHAPTER 8: EXPLAINING TO HER
GRANDFATHER THAT YOU'RE CHINESE
AND HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
PEARL HARBOR.
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHAPTER 4, APPROACHING HER
CAVERNOUS VAGINA.
>> POINTS.
( APPLAUSE )
>> THAT'S BECAUSE WHITE WOMEN
ALL HAVE HUGE VAGINE AS.
>> OH, MY GOODNESS, YES.
>> IT'S ALL RELATIVE, LADY
LADIES.
IT'S ALL RELATIVE.
>> YOU'LL FIND THE RIGHT GUY.
>> NEXT ONE, ASS GOBLINS OF
AUSCHWITZ.
WHAT'S THE CHAPTER FROM THIS
BOOK?
MAX?
>> HEIL, (BLEEP)LER
>> IT WAS RIGHT THERE THE WHOLE
TIME. POINTS. NICK.
>> CHAPTER NINE, NEIN!
>> WELL PLAYED.
WELL PLAYED, MR POLYMATH.
KRISTEN.
>> CHAPTER 13-- UP THE BUTT
FROM GERBILS TO GOEBBELS.
>> OH, THAT WAS SO GOOD. POINTS.
POINTS!
>> IS THAT YOURS POINTS DANCE?
>> SHAKE THOSE OWL EYES, BABY!
>> WHY AM I DOING THIS FOR YOU?
>> DON'T LET HIM TREAT YOU LIKE
THAT.
YOU DON'T DESERVE THAT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY WHY I'M
DANCING LIKE A MONKEY.
>> JUST FOR A SECOND I FELT LIKE
I WAS GETTING ( BLEEP ) BY A
MUSTACHE.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THAT WAS.
>> YEAH, YOU ALWAYS FEEL THAT
WAY.
( APPLAUSE ).
>> POINT!
POINTS, KRISTEN SCHAAL
NEXT ONE.
ANYBODY CAN BE COOL, BUT AWESOME
TAKES PRACTICE. NICK.
>> CHAPTER 3-- BUY CIGARETTES
FOR A THIRD GRADER.
>> YOU WOULD LOOK TOTALLY COOL
IF YOU DID THAT.
POINT.
>> CHAPTER ONE-- YOU BOUGHT THIS
BOOK TOO LATE.